Hogy viseled ezeket a pofonokat? Ez nem
az a műfaj, ahol nagyon sokáig menne a
konfliktus kerül, és azt látom. Szóval
már vannak konfliktusok, amiket fel
kellett váralni, és most jönnek
sorjában, amikor például a
költségvetésről van szó, és tudatosítani
kell intézményvezetőkbe, tudatosítani
kell olyan jellegű kedvezményezettekkel,
mint a sportegyesületek
képviselői, mint a különféle
rendezvényszervezők, a kulturális
egyesületek, a civil szervezetek
képviselő, hogy nincs pénz. Mindenhol
egy kicsit visszább kell venni. Tehát
nem ebben az évben kell valami óriási
nagyot álmodni, mert nem bírja meg a
költségvetés és a közös teherviselést.
Ilyen szempontból nagyon fontosnak
látom. Tehát meg kell értenie azt a
helyi rendőrség vezetőjének, de a
színházigazgatónak is, de az
iskolaigazgatónak is, hogy egész
egyszerűen anyagilag nem fogjuk bírni
ebben az évben azt, hogy nagyobb álmokat
valósítsunk meg. Tehát most tényleg
össze kell húzni egy kicsit a nagyjat.
Nem voltam erre én sem felkészítve vagy
felkészülve, és
nem szeretem, nem ismerem ezt a műfajt,
amikor amikor rossz híreket kell közölni
emberekkel. De most már kezdek
belejönni.